hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es ein sehr
schnelles rezept ich werde ein pesto
machen und weil gerade bei lok saison
ist wenn ich einen bärlauch pesto machen
wer bärlauch nicht kennt also das
schmeckt und riecht ein bisschen nach
knoblauch sieht aber ganz anders aus
bärlauch gibt es zurzeit auch im wald
das kann man auch sammeln
ich habs jetzt nicht selber gesammelt
aber ich gehe wahrscheinlich mit samira
und mit murat und mit unseren freunden
wald denn der zeigt mir dann worauf man
achten muss beim bahnhof sammeln und so
weiter wobei man auch immer am geruch
erkennt also findet es im wald sammeln
geht und ihr sohn blatt ab er wisse
nicht genau ist bella oder später bricht
einfach dran unterricht hat echt nach
knoblauch und dieses pesto kündet zum
beispiel auch ganz klassisch machen mit
basilikum dann habt ihr ganz normales
basilikum pesto aber wie gesagt heute
berlau für die zubereitung braucht ihr
100 gramm bärlauch 50 gramm parmesankäse
und das gramm pinienkerne und 100
milliliter olivenöl und das ganze
reichtum für etwa 500 gramm nudeln ich
nehm das später bandnudeln zuerst gebe
ich jetzt meine pinienkerne in einer
pfanne und tröstete sie da drin und die
zeit kann ich auch nutzen um gleich mein
wasser aufzukochen wo ich dann gleich
die noten auf kochen kann also insgesamt
dauert es vielleicht nicht länger als
zehn minuten und ihr habt dann ein
warmes essen auf dem teller stehen was
eben auch sehr gut
ich habe sie viele gerne an geäußert um
die nudeln kochen auch bereits jetzt
sind die kopien keine bisserl ab ich
gebe es jetzt in den mixer rein das geht
jetzt auch alles ganz schnell
als ob die welt kurz gemixt
dann kommt da der bärlauch mit dazu den
zusätzlichen angeht so schneller als
rein
wer jetzt eine küchenmaschine hat kann
auch ein staatlicher benutzen also das
geht auch hier hat mal die hände
freiheit wegen schlusslicht ist
einfacher
jetzt kommt noch dass olivenöl mit dazu
100 milliliter
pastor bekommt immer viel öl mit rein
das könnte so damit rein und dann lässt
sich das jetzt auf gleich richtig gut
durch nicht sein aber auch halter die
flüssigkeit
jetzt muss ich ganz schnell schon meine
mutter abgeben sonst sind die nämlich
vermischt
und jetzt muss ich noch ein paar gläsern
klein machen den hätte ich eigentlich am
anfang direkt klein machen wollen habe
ich jetzt vergessen
deswegen nehme ich jetzt kurzes msv
schlimm aber um es noch die arbeit zu
sparen nämlich ihre schreiberei und 50
gramm kann
nur durch mixa
wer möchte gibt jetzt noch ein bisschen
salz mit dazu das hat vermehrt gestern
auch ein bisschen gefehlt und stand
können wir das gleich serviert
jetzt könnte einfach die nudeln mit dem
pesto vermischen
ich mache das jetzt viermal in der mit
glas und eigentlich immer so die soße
wartet auf die nudeln und nicht die
noten auf das wasser deswegen sind meine
diesel verklebten also eigentlich immer
erst immer so planen dass zuerst das
pesto fertig ist und dann die note
einfach so viel wie ihr möchtet als ich
nehme immer zuerst etwas weniger
und dann gucken wir mal ich hätte doch
einfach heißes wasser zur nudel geben
können wenn sie auch noch verklebt
aber es gibt ja
jetzt können wir das einfach anrichten
und wenn ihr jetzt sagt ich hab ich
möchte nicht so eine große portion
machen macht eine kleinere oder ich
empfehle euch man kann das passt auch
gut aufheben ich zeige euch auch gleich
wie könnte einfach die menge machen und
aufbewahren im kühlschrank oder zum
beispiel einfache bisserl was
verschenken ich glaube es reicht
dann einfach noch ob es an drüber
und fertig ist das bärlauch pesto mit
bandnudeln und ich finde es sieht nicht
nur lecker aus richtung lecker schmeckt
auch richtig gut vor allem ist ein
günstiges rezept gut die pinienkerne
sinn ist das einzige was etwas teurer
ist aber ihr braucht er im prinzip nur
vier zutaten plus eur nudeln
deswegen finde ich kann man sich das
schon mal leisten dass wir pinienkernen
und zu machen
ansonsten wäre die alternative mit
sonnenblumenkernen so ist es oftmals
auch im fertigen pestos zu finden weil
es einfach kostengünstiger ist aber ich
finde die kombination perfekt und ihr
müsst ihr einfach mal ausprobieren
und wenn jetzt zum beispiel pesto
aufbewahren wollt oder verschenken
wollte gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten ich hab jetzt von gestern
noch fest da ich hab das rezept nämlich
gestern auch schon mal gemacht und
entwickler könnt ihr jetzt so weckgläser
nehmen also die gibt's ja in klein und
groß finde ich ganz löst denn man kann
das einfach schön ein film
dass ich jetzt erhalte bistum als ihr
seht schon ein bisschen dicker geworden
dann am besten kleine löcher
und dann könnte das nämlich abschließen
mit etwas olivenöl
so wird es an haltbar gemacht
und dann einfach rechts und links
verschließen oder wenn er sagt ich habe
keine weckgläser und ich finde es auch
sogar noch schöner wenn man einfach so
ein kleines gläschen nimmt das waren
jetzt bei mir ich hab dir diese bagdad
gewürze und wenn ihr da diese folie
vorne weg macht dinge ist gewiss schon
aufgebraucht habt ich habe auch die
pinienkerne jetzt aus dem glas gehabt
dann können da die folie mit etwas kühle
wasser weg machen und wenn so ein
biathlet einfach in die spülmaschine und
da können das auch schön drin servieren
gläser also die hebe ich mir auch immer
auf teams auch schon schöne fordert dann
kann man auch schön das etikett vom
rumpf leben und das auch darin servieren
oder verschenken
da könne da zum beispiel einfach ein
etikett rom machen und das ganze noch
schön mit einem geschenk band verpacken
und das mache ich jetzt gleich ein foto
und wenn ihr dieses rezept nach machen
wollt geht einfach auf meinem blog auf
cellestis blog.de wir lassen uns gleich
die nudeln schmecken und wie sie beim
nächsten mal wieder